go to scheme calm now everyone's all
messed up you haven't even started it
for up really welcome back to the
podcast brought to you by you guessed it
skin go to skin calm / denden Julian to
get started with the newsletter that
makes understanding what's going on in
the world much easier every morning they
send completely free newsletter to your
email letting you know all the news bits
that you need to know and it's
completely free and if you use our URL
you were entered for the chance to win a
$250 Visa gift card or hit the link in
the description down below I'm a DJ now
also guys Squarespace if you're looking
to build a website do it with
Squarespace they make it so amazingly
easy
they have templates options tools to
make your website exactly how you'd like
it go to Squarespace calm / Jenna
Juliana get 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain do it you would
like it I think you should do it thank
you sponsors welcome to that welcome to
the show everybody we're hitting it
running today
welcome back what are you doing oh god
your energy my why don't we recap really
quick yeah week a couple knobs we came
in the room in my chair for some reason
was super to get rewind I feel like
we've been podcasting where I'm super
tall this we have your time I'm really
close to the same height as you you're
4/9 [ __ ] oh don't say that you can't say
that because now people can take that
out of context and use it against me you
can't undo it they say oh it's 11 okay
yeah you're not for 9 there you go ok
let's recap further back than what you
recapped because that's not fair
ok I'm patiently waiting for you to do
your makeup yeah no don't sit I did it
I'm ready hello then she comes in here
and
pulls out her phone and starts taking
pictures and videos and saying hey hey
it's me and I'm like okay hey like
what's up
so then you take this whole video where
I'm standing up fixing the camera and
you're like on the screen behind me and
then I'm like laughing at you because
you're being goofy and you're like this
is a funny video right chapeau so I'm
like yeah it's really cute post it and
then you look at me and delete it and
then I'm like what is happening today I
think something might be funny and then
I watch it again I'm like I don't like
it so why don't why even I post it why
even get my input because if I said it's
not funny
would you I'm a human being and I like
to have you input you don't get to just
have my input for fun I I will listen to
your input and then won't take it but
I'm a Virgo if you don't take my input
I'm really offended you know fair enough
fair enough
Virgo you get to choose whose input is
worth your time mmm-hmm are you keep
touching so we don't have an audio
engineer on set so I gotta turn the knob
that's you okay but I'm also the talent
okay I got a B on screen I gotta be on
cam people need to see this I can't just
be behind behind the cameras and
adjusting settings I'm I'm a one-man
band making applications for someone
that wants to just sneak around the room
actually I'm a tute we're a two-man band
sorry I'm not a one fin I'm a one-man
why I am a one-man band
but in this podcast I am just part of a
bigger to men band and you're the other
man but in general I am I wear a lot of
hats they're all size 7 and 1/4 baby why
do you know that cuz I wore hats as a
kid didn't your head girl once it
stopped once it stopped really growing
that was my
I filled it up with enough information
so it stops growing then it was the same
hat size it'd be sick if you're like my
head stopped going when I was like six
honestly convenient cuz then you could
wear all your childhood hats as an adult
yeah right yeah yeah exactly what the
[ __ ] no you were making fun of me
non-stop so that's how we started what
happened
you open the pod casting the skin and
the skin won't be happy about that
my energy is normal yours is chaotic
I'll tell you one thing I am
consistently chaotic there is
consistence in the madness you are being
weird right now and you're not always
weird something is off with you tonight
well oh no I like that you're having a
good time is weird good time to what I
said I posted a picture on it sorry for
yesterday
you're my favorite Instagram and posts I
think you should win streaming of
Instagram fluent sir
that's your award I literally we were
about to go stream and I'm laying on the
couch and like I never post on Instagram
ever it's not that I don't I love
Instagram I like it use it all the time
but like I just don't really post like
I'll post on my story yeah but I was
just like laying down I just looked like
such an [ __ ] and I was like Julian
should I post sorry for never posted on
Instagram and I took a picture of me
laughing like it was it was funny it was
funny
I like how you uh what I think I like
how went and just sometimes you'll wake
up and be like okay I'm gonna [ __ ] post
on Instagram today yeah twice a year
like maybe once a year do you never post
on that platform yeah what do you have
against it what's your beef
nothing I just don't like posting
pictures of myself you know you have to
post pictures of yourself you play fish
that little rat or whatever you want
yeah I just don't like posting pictures
Wow here's the thing like having picture
I agree with you
because I feel like well I obviously
agree with you do an extent because I
still post on Instagram sometimes I'm
very bad at it but I feel like the way
Instagram is kind of like is as a
platform where people scroll through
pictures and either like not like
comment or not comment like there's a
lot of pressure especially because the
post stays on your page forever there's
a lot of pressure with each post that
you're like I don't know if this is
worth like an actual post especially
when there's Instagram stories there's
Twitter things get buried easier on
Twitter stories better like snapchat a
lot I would regularly post on snapchat
and I semi-regularly put story like
pictures on my stories yeah but not
necessarily of me I I agree I don't post
I really don't post like selfies really
or pictures of myself I mean I sometimes
post pictures myself it's just kind of
weird for me to be like ok I'm gonna go
take a picture I'm you know here's me
I'm like I'm on the internet enough as
it is like do I also need to post
pictures myself constantly well yes
please do more I'd like to see more of
you
on the internet um but no like so
sometimes all what's weird is like I'll
take a lot of pictures or I'll have a
lot of pictures ready or edited or
whatever and I hand up not posting any
of them because I'm like afraid of not
picking the right one yeah you don't
mean so I'm like paralyzed by like the
fear of not making the perfect post and
that is that is oftentimes why I don't
think it's wrong but I just sometimes
don't like the the culture of it yeah
the like glamorous life culture of
Instagram kind of makes me a little sad
yeah it makes everybody a little sad
it's a sad thing it's a very superficial
platform yeah an experience as a and it
makes you feel like you're not like good
enough but that's like so not true and
no one's life is like that and everyone
knows that but it's still kind of like
sad and not my favorite yeah true
because like on Twitter for instance
it's hella funny it's funny as funnies
being a [ __ ] when you follow people for
something less shallow than just their
face yeah and like you see their profile
pic or whatever that is
for that person but most of the time
you're there because you want to hear
them talk and tick tock is the realest
[ __ ] out there Tech Talk is not the real
love tick-tock it can be funny like 10
percent of the time how dare you what
what do you think what percentage do you
think tick tock is funny I'd say every
six tick tocks that I see make me laugh
out loud when I'm just browsing that for
fair ratio
I watched I've watched you watch tic
TOCs it's at least one 1/8 wide in
eighty that is not true I'm song you
think every six yeah
want to try it right now yeah try it
right now okay yeah I guarantee you well
right y'all well should the Jenna and
Julian podcast where we watched tic TOCs
without [ __ ] you can't see anything
you can just only hear the tick-tock
yeah welcome you know this is
high-quality entertainment so I closed
and reopen the app so now it's gonna
give me a fresh for you tab oh yeah I
have bad service up here a man dancing
in a parking lot okay that's it okay
that's one this is a video of someone
getting their cap off or their I'm sorry
cast oh my god what kind of procedure is
that this is kind of gross and I kind of
I don't want to see that I don't want to
see their eyes that too this is a girl
dancing no she's tying a ribbon in her
hair
Oh fun
ooh life hack okay beautiful amazing she
just made her long hair look kind of
short with a ribbon Wow right she's
chugging a bottle of water by smashing
the bottle into her mouth you're
laughing you are laughing you're
laughing and that was came out of your
nose
she's smashed into her mouth and it
knows for
no men right I don't know am i right
oh okay okay she's partying the hair
beautiful I'm so bored - tik-tok wait I
don't get it is this really just a hair
tutorial oh I thought you said spit I
thought she said spit - he's the problem
with you talk I'll tell you the problem
tick-tock there's [ __ ] like that where
you're like I don't know what I'm
watching yeah but that's a one-in-four
right now not funny they should not be
laughing she's just doing like the
pretending that she's walking on stairs
behind a counter this is how - basic
tick-tock but it's not you know it's not
it's an account that's it's literally
it's sixteen by nine like it's a video
from YouTube they put on tick tock okay
okay I'm laughing alone okay Julian see
I told you you're lying okay we're gonna
like three more in your argument listen
the ratio is just kind of thrown off
here I don't
good okay listen can I say something I'm
right and you know it you're right gave
it a generous ratio and it's even higher
than that okay babe you're a [ __ ] Wow
listen all right there once was a time
in a very very not so distant past where
you would scroll through the just
heaping hot piles of garbage on that app
for twenty thirty minutes on it and then
you would burst out laughing worth it
worth it to me but my point unless a
he's not worth it
not worth it I'm sorry but my point is
that like it wasn't always this
plentiful and maybe later it won't
always be as plentiful but yes it'll be
found a couple fun easy cars right now
no that is not true
when it was musically yeah not funny not
fun not a good place to be especially 30
like I think it's not okay
but now yeah it's [ __ ] tight well
it's actually funny yeah okay okay
you said it everyone in what 8 or 10 I
said 8 no you said 10% it's a 10 no one
said percentages this is shifty and
weird cuz I never said before yes you
are you look really cute yeah and I'm
not for 9 well we wanted to uh you're
looking for ideas for podcast I look
through ear biscuits because they always
have great ideas and they did one where
they talked about their most influential
TV shows that kind of like as a child or
as a young adult influenced them in
whatever way or you know stuck with them
means a lot to them so we what we
basically did was we had each of us
compiled a list of like what 7 was super
hard to pick just 5 yeah so we have 14
total 7 each television shows are you
called
yeah I just got a shiver I'm a hoodie no
way my hoodie it's comfy
that's just a plain like sweatshirt that
has nothing printed on it yet the sample
is this not fashioned is this not
high-fashion
no I'm cold
ok offering you one don't take the worth
don't want it why I don't want it you
would prefer to complain about being
yeah my hair my I'll just put your arms
in it and not put
your head no oh you just thought about
that and then realize that was my
solution so you don't want to say yes
sir oh just I'll stand behind the green
screen or something you go ahead you
what's your first on the list not a
minor like particularly sentimental
honestly and they were all in there but
there's much for my just influential ooh
okay number one influential show well
these are in no particular order but the
first one that I have is all that which
was like a kid's sketch comedy arrive is
like Saturday Night Live for kids I
remember during the afternoon and Kenan
Thompson was on it and like I thought
about it the other day when he was on
sorry I live because I still adore him
and it's just the perfect job for him
and always husband Kenan Thompson has
been making me laugh like pee my pants
with laughter my entire life like that
is so [ __ ] dope I remember all that
because he was a kid on the show and I
was a kid too and it like makes it extra
funny when he had that Pierre escargot
character that's in the bathtub and it's
just saying silly sentences in French
yeah and then he tells you he's like you
know let the dumb I'm sorry there was a
terrible friendship but then it's like I
like to put peanut butter in my shoes
yeah I thought that [ __ ] was the
funniest thing I've ever seen
Beach mm-hmm but it was really cool I'm
pretty sure unless it was a show called
like roundhouse or something there was
like a little sometimes I would dance
sometimes they would like that was
roundhouse that was round okay
roundhouse was like a live dancing show
which I liked a lot never heard of that
there were like a bunch of them in the
90s like some cool like dance shows
roundhouse yeah honestly probably should
have put TRL on here you can end your
list all that that was a good show I
remember watching
do you remember TGIF yeah yeah just oh
man we had some really good shows mm-hmm
good first one thank you I'm gonna
preface my list by saying I didn't watch
a whole lot of TV growing up I watched
some there were definitely years in my
childhood get a TV what did I get a TV
we had TVs but it was nothing it was
just about like kid
time with it but yeah like like middle
school in high school I didn't watch TV
as a child child I got you know I just
didn't watch much but there's no cable
right no we have like basic cable
tension whatever Spongebob Squarepants
is one of the most influential shows for
me I watched that a lot when I was young
I watched I'm pretty sure I've watched
every episode maybe not some of the
newer ones but I've watched spongebob
for years and years of my life I've
learned about things via SpongeBob like
life things via the show of Spongebob
and I learned about comedy like there's
a lot of comedy lessons that are being
like kind of taught to kids in that show
and and I realized that a lot of my
humor comes from watching that show
really yeah yeah I mean and also just
like you know that was like my first
episodic TV show that I really was
committed to watching like regularly or
watching anytime I had free time to like
pop on some spongebob that was kind of
my main first show that I ever really
got spun joke to me like it came out
when I was babysitting kids so like
we're watching it yeah so well they
didn't really like that they liked more
calm stuff like I don't know not
cartoons they would watch I forget what
they would watch but just like chill
like mr. Rogers type energy yeah I'm
saying no but I was already like
babysitting kids so I like couldn't get
into it because to me I was like you
know what a young teenager
yeah and that was a kids show that I
like wasn't into you know I mean so I
know it's like this big cultural thing
no not that at all but like you know
once you turn into a teenager and you
now have privileges to watch like
different types of television or great
types of movies that are really
interesting to you that no longer is
something that's appealing at all
totally I get why as a teenager you
wouldn't want to start watching
spongebob I get ya wasn't into it and
then as an adult now I feel like I
missed out on so much because I have
seen a fair amount of it as an adult but
like it's not what I grew up watching I
grew up watching Ren and Stimpy though
hmm
yeah so like in the honorable mention on
this
so many honorable mention yeah like well
just like for cartoons there's like
there's cat dog there's Hey Arnold
there's rats there's rocket power
there's like all the shows that I did
Jimmy [ __ ] Neutron did you ever watch
that show dude I remember when i watched
Jimmy Neutron and I was like how the
[ __ ] do they have the [ __ ] technology
to make these animations they are so
mind-blowing because Jimmy Neutron had
like these weird futuristic he was
really good yeah yeah it was like
different than what was out at the time
for sure and I don't know I mean it was
just a different style it was kind of
weird and robotic in its own way but I
remember thinking that show is so dope
and like future is ticking cool yeah I
think a lot of people would say
spongebob squarepants yeah yeah within
your same age great yeah I would agree
and it's interesting because I feel like
and this may just be my perception but
then again like my perception is kind of
everything in my existence but anyway
like you know like I feel like the last
couple of years I've seen more and more
Sponge Bob become like president in meme
culture you know II mean the mr. Krabs
meme like all this even that sweet
victory at yeah exactly and that was
like one of the most iconic spongebob
episode that was one of the most signed
change.org org petitions that they
wanted it to be at the Superbowl it was
I know for a million yeah anyway [ __ ]
funny yeah spongebob be like all right
I'll be like what's shown next one I'm
sorry I'd shut my phone off that's a guy
okay I think this goes without saying
but Seinfeld's okay so he was in there
somewhere
my brother absolutely loved Seinfeld and
at first it like you know it's a little
too young to sort of catch on to really
what was happening and like was a little
disinterested but by the time I got to
high school it was something that we
were just like regularly crying laughing
at
absolutely crying laughing at like I
wasn't really into friends I wasn't
allowed to watch like Beverly Hills I
know - oh no of like you know Baywatch
or any of the
Melrose Place like all of that was too
mature for me but my mom would let us
watch Seinfeld and it like my brother so
we had like a pretty small like a living
room and we had a couch in it and a
coffee table and our heat vents were
like in the floor so it's like a grate
on the floor like a square yeah I had
this and so my brother would it's
[ __ ] freezing all the time right and
my brother first of all was too tall to
lay like on the couch and no one else
could use the couch so you put pillows
on the floor and lay on the floor in
front of the TV but he was too tall to
fit like just straight up facing the TV
so he diagonally across the entire
living room so that he could watch
Seinfeld and you know we did have a VCR
so we could you know tape television
shows but when Seinfeld was on like good
luck everyone
Devin's watching Seinfeld and he would
take his blanket and put it over the
grapes [ __ ] feet on it so he would
absorb all of the heat he's tired
downstairs like that was the good one
that was the one that really kept us
warm you know so he would fall asleep
all the time on the [ __ ] on the floor
with the heat blasting into his blanket
so I was like lifting up there was
blasting in there so high and me and my
mom are [ __ ] freezing
well I also had a ferret too so my
favorite would come downstairs she would
always run over to Devin like ferret
under the blanket and nip his ankle and
he was like the opposite of Kermit she
would fight this [ __ ] to just go to you
so funny he put the blanket over the
grate so he was just absorbing
everything yeah but like when I think of
Seinfeld I think of like all the happy
memories like my brother has like the
best laugh like he is so funny
I love hearing
he's so tall he's like Kramer in a lot
of ways and it just like he is so goofy
I honestly I wish I could have seen him
as a kid like yes so funny like it so
that Seinfeld obviously now is one of my
favorite shows of all time it's
absolutely hilarious yeah but like it
reminds me of like spending time at my
house with my brother while just crying
laughing and or asleep and hogging all
the heat like it's just like a nice
memory you know that that show evokes
for me and yeah I think it shapes a lot
of people's humor when you watch that
just like the office or parks and rag
totally like that kind of show that kind
of comedy like always stays with you
yeah you know I would definitely agree
yeah that's so cool well also like I
think I loved Steve Martin so much
growing up but like I liked comedians
that did things or like you know comedy
that was funny just because it's funny
it's just silly
like it just is you know yeah it's not
at anybody's expense it's not like
trying to do anything other than like
it's a little ridiculous yeah I mean
obviously if you go back and watch some
Seinfeld now there's some problematic
things in there with literally every
show it was just silly to be silly and
it was just funny
just [ __ ] was you you proud of me I
was out in the world with another human
being and they dropped a Seinfeld
reference and I was keen to it I'm so
again it happened again and I was like I
remembered what they were talking about
I wasn't just like yeah sure yeah yeah
it was the he was talking about when
Jerry said when when George had his
glasses right and he couldn't see he's
like didn't his glasses or whatever and
he spots the nickel across the room and
then he takes a bite of the onion and
Jerry is like I don't know what to
believe your spot nickels eaten now you
know anyway I also remember that
Squarespace is a really great way to
build a website it's an all-in-one
platform that helps you create an online
presence that you don't
do not tickle me don't tickle me in your
knee pit don't tell me anything guys if
you have these ideas that you want to
build into a proper presence online
photography music musicians if you're
musicians if you're a graphic designer
whatever your passion might be if you
want to have proper presence in the
website form do a Squarespace if you
have a podcast like us do a Squarespace
we use square space it's amazing they
have all the tools that you need as a
person who may not know how to do
anything about building website with
coding or anything like that even you
know graphic designing anything like
that they make it very easy to make your
website look professional
they have 24/7 customer support
award-winning customer support which
makes the process of creating your
website so much smoother and 24/7 is is
real that's not just a saying they are
around the clock there for you to help
you out when you are trying to make your
website beautiful and exactly the way
you want it for all platforms for
desktop for mobile for tablets make it
look how you want it do with Squarespace
is amazing right now all you have to do
is head to Squarespace that's squ a RESP
a see e-comm slash Jenna Julian you get
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain also you can check it out for
a free trial right now at
squarespace.com slash Julian check it
out the skin guys the skin is the way
that you should be getting your info on
what is going on in the world if you
want to go on Twitter go on Twitter and
have your fun and learn your Twitter
things but when you need the bare bones
facts about what's going on get the
newsletter sent to you from the skin
that's th e sk IMM comm / Jenna Julian
you just go to that URL or click the
link in the description and you sign up
click your email and hit subscribe it is
completely free that is all we ask and
you can test it out see how you like it
right every morning you're gonna in your
inbox you're gonna say okay here's the
skin what do they have to offer and then
you're gonna read through this game and
then you are just one level up from
people who didn't read the skin that day
you were in the know about all the
things that you should be in the know
about very useful informations and a
really bite-sized easy to digest format
also guys Oprah loves the skin so do it
okay
that's the sales pitch just do it Oprah
likes it so the four million other
people right now it's completely free
when you sign up at the skin home Santa
Julian also using that URL gives you a
chance to win a how much two hundred and
fifty dollar Visa gift card what would
you do with the VFC guard I would give
it to you why wait I would buy things
that wouldn't be traced back to me
because it's a gift card my god why are
you like this I'm just kidding I would
be gifted to someone else I'm curious
about this next one on my list if you
have it as well okay what is it Beach
Family Guy no I put Family Guy on there
I mean it is now for me yeah I would yet
well it wasn't when I was younger my
brother adored the first couple seasons
and then it got cancelled and then it
came back yeah and like yeah it's
probably one of my favorite TV shows
ever but I wouldn't say that it played a
role in like making me as a person yeah
I guess it's I was I was kind of
second-guessing if I should have put
down the list and maybe it's an
honorable mention for me it is for me
for sure but I watched a lot of it with
my dad like late middle school early
high school years when we would go to my
dad's house and that's all the TV I
would watch was at my dad's house like I
didn't get to really watch I got the
watch TV at my dad's house - it was the
weekend I get to go over on Tuesdays and
Thursdays and I would watch hey dude I
would watch guts salute your shorts
right Cambon wanna we hold you in our
hearts yeah oh I used to watch a lot of
Nickelodeon like I didn't really watch
the Disney Channel I wasn't into that I
would watch Nickelodeon yep oh man those
were the [ __ ]
honorable mention I watched it a lot it
was very funny growing up as still as
funny so it feels like good you know
important show to me I feel like that
though like I have a couple of shows on
on my list like Seinfeld is me and my
brother yeah
that you know that's whatever I don't
know what I'm trying to say but the
shows that you like watch and enjoy with
your parents are really special yeah
yeah I used to watch I'm pretty sure I
mentioned before I used to watch test
for housewives with my dad and it was
like back when I didn't I was in middle
school and I didn't know it was an event
when it came out Sunday nights I like I
told you they played the the first ad or
something for like during the Superbowl
one year or something like that we were
all watching TV which was not always a
circle yeah and they were like Desperate
Housewives coming you know this big long
trailer that would just blew everyone's
minds cuz they were like wow this is
racy as hell what is going on and they
were like coming sundays at eight or
whatever my brother just looks at all of
us and goes oh he was definitely booked
yeah I remember God he also had a time
when he loved the song bailamos by
Enrique Iglesias would only play that
and dance around to it
just that one song beautiful he was a
lot yeah that's why I like him though we
share that we share that trait all right
yeah the real world
yeah the real world to me it was a show
that by the time I was in high school my
mom would watch it with us and like
obviously that was a groundbreaking
style of show and we saw like you know
when you're a young adult that stuff is
really appealing to you
yeah like watching people a little bit
older than you living their lives you
know living together partying hooking up
with each other what I like all the
things that you're looking forward to
doing someday hopefully you know you're
like growing up yeah well you're in high
school yeah and whatever while doing
crazy things but like that show also did
a lot of good by having a lot of
different types of people on there some
of which were the first time that you
would see that person on TV yeah you
know which was really [ __ ] cool later
what these types of really
chips actually look like in real life
not portrayed by an actor you know not
but that's a bad thing either like
visibility is visibility
but it was like really cool really fun
really entertaining and reality
television wasn't like all over the
place yet and it was just you know
everybody's favorite [ __ ] show in my
age group and my mom would watch it with
us and she would like it yeah and that
was like [ __ ] tight you know what I'm
saying cuz you're like I'm watching
something it's like a little bit old for
me you know cuz I'm young but my mom's
here watching it and she's just as
invested as I am oh yeah but like you
said when you watch stuff with your
parents that holds it yeah well my mom
would also be like reading a magazine or
like doing a crossword and I'd be on the
floor and my mom be on the couch behind
me and we would watch the real world and
then she'd look up like especially my
brother went to college we watch it
together
girls night yeah and my mom would like
you know look up from her magazine be
like [ __ ] I you know what someday I
would love to watch all of the real
world
I have watched so little is so fantastic
and I feel like my introduction to the
real world came at the hands of the
challenge like I learned about the
challenge via you and and then I
automatically loved it because it was
like it was that but it was competition
and I love that whole formula so yeah we
binge watch how many [ __ ] seasons
when we first started dating and I was
like in love with that show and I we
still watch it but yeah I'd love to
rewind and really watch the real well
because I've you know I feel like it is
one of those things where it's like it's
a cultural kind of you know big thing
that I missed at the time but it's still
just as cool to like go back and see
what it was like yeah well I mean when
it came out we had game shows with real
contestants we had survivor which had
just come out like but that's a game
show in essence you know I didn't really
have a lot of just watching other people
like live their lives you know so it was
one of a kind you know wasn't there
wasn't a lot of stuff like it yep and it
was really cool to see that we had some
documentary style stuff
like it's not like you didn't watch
anybody in real life but it was just a
weekly thing with young people on it and
at the beginning it was definitely
revolutionary I feel like if you were to
go back and watch it some of it wouldn't
land quite the same yeah sure yeah you
know because it was [ __ ] rad yeah but
then I I watched every season and I
watched the challenge and I still watch
the challenge like I love it it's
[ __ ] quality energy challenges good
man well because it gives you all of
their drama personally and all of them
just like they can't stop they can't
stop like so much all they do is just
the [ __ ] drink and fight oh my god we
had Sarah on the podcast she was
wonderful it was really [ __ ] dope for
me because it it's just I love that
stuff but um the more recent seasons of
the real world I feel like kind of are
just dying I don't I mean I don't even
know when the last time they made one
was because we have YouTube now you know
on the internet yeah we have a
saturation of reality content now at
this point where it's it doesn't really
quite land and it seems like they were
trying to just put you know a racist
person in a house with a person of color
and you're like let's see what happens
well is it like this is kind of [ __ ]
like why are you subjecting these people
to this well that I mean that's why
really horrible things being said and
really awful situations but in my
opinion and I've seen the clip you're
talking about and like the last season
or whatever in my opinion that's why the
real the real world isn't succeeding in
these days it's not that the formats
tired or that it's on YouTube is that
they're trying so hard to separate Tara
but they're being just bad and so like
no one wants to be associated with that
like there's a reason why that shows
dying well I mean that's subjective
obviously it might not be dying but you
perceive it as such well there's a
reason why that challenge is overtaking
well yeah like the game show aspect
along with the people living their real
life and but but big brother is still
[ __ ] popular people still watch the
[ __ ] out of that that's a game show and
people living the real lives yes but
it's very symmetric survivor no no no
the real world has no endgame
it's just following people around while
they live and the fake job you don't
think people watch Big Brother to watch
people live you think it's only for the
competition I'm saying that but I'm
saying the real world has no other
second layers yes just reality
yeah no no like there there's a game
show in Big Brother yeah no I know but
in the Venn diagram between Big Brother
and the real world there is a very
common ground of like watching people
just live for yeah yeah that's that's
calling what I'm saying like I know that
Big Brother has has a goal or an end
gamer you can win or whatever but there
is still a lot of similarities and Big
Brother doing very well that's that was
my only point yeah well so survivor so a
lot of shows but if there is a game
element are you some of them yeah it is
incredible that survivors are still
thriving and doing better than I really
[ __ ] show that show is so cool every
every season we watch it's just like
anyways what's your next one let's pop
this open okay this this show I was
thinking about shows that I knew
influenced me as a kid hmm as a kid not
as like a young adult or a high school
no like a kid and I remembered with the
help of my sister she actually texted it
to me because I was like what shows do
we wash even Stevens
dude that was Disney I'm 90% sure is he
Shia LaBeouf being a younger brother who
is just off his [ __ ] rocker just
annoying the [ __ ] out of everyone at all
at all times I was began your lifelong
love affair with Shia LaBeouf that is
where my love from comes from for Shia
LaBeouf how many times did you watch
that elastic heart video like thousands
and Counting I own stopped that show
like I watched it so much when I was I
was him too because I would take notes
on how he annoyed his big sister and I
would do that - rocks - Roxanne I would
like I would messed up well no that was
just me putting like knowledge into
action as a child and learning from the
best but for real like I watch that show
so much oh my god I watch that show so
much
I like learned about how to be crazy and
you know control as a child and it was
like that was the show you learned how
to be crazy and out of control I
actually read a lot of my Airy strength
to that to watching that show not it was
a good show to be fair it was a great
show a great show I didn't watch a lot
of it but it was probably my favorite
Disney Channel show that I watched yeah
even Stephens you're watching even
Stephens with the yeah I never really
got that until it was an adult because I
just didn't get that I didn't watch a
lot of Disney
sorry good she doesn't get the moon
really never saw any of them show me
home I've seen one episode of Wizards of
Waverly Place because my friend Kim was
doing my hair and had it on in the
background like that was it I didn't
watch any Hannah Montana
I'm here Montana called yeah get in here
yeah so sorry Suite Life of Zack & Cody
same thing yeah I didn't watch that yeah
same
what's your next one um Star Trek The
Next Generation we're checking across
the universe I'd say on this list this
is one of the shows that shaped me the
most
really yeah because I would again I
would watch it at my dad's house yep and
it was like the first time that I think
cuz I would watch like full house and
Family Matters like all the sort of
family comedies that comes whatever and
you know they would try and throw a life
lesson in there sometimes you know and I
always even as a kid sort of thought
they came off a little like annoying or
cheesy like let's let's get a good funny
episode you know like I came to laugh at
the preaching at the Olsen twins like I
don't want to watch an episode where
somebody's dead and everyone's crying
like yeah thanks I appreciate them like
I was a kid I wanted to be entertained
yeah sure we didn't have another escape
unless you wanted to listen to the radio
or read a book or go outside and take a
tree or something so I used to do Star
Trek I feel like the next generation
which was the the series that was on
when I was a kid and it was the first
time that like the messages of the show
were actually sinking into me as a
person and I appreciated them I enjoyed
them and I felt like I learned a lot
like not only was it entertaining
it was futuristic it was fun I liked all
of the the people I liked when it was
funny I liked when it was serious I
liked when it was dramatic I liked
everything about it and I genuinely felt
like it was making me a better person a
more knowledgeable person about life
experiences that I had not had yet you
know I mean I agree having watched a
handful of seasons as an adult because
you showed it to me it is very very cool
and special watching that show and
seeing the undertones kind of come
through as as in the time that it did
like so many years ago
having you know these points that are in
ways like still kind of relevant today
it is a cool thing and I think I would
have liked to gotten into that show as a
kid yeah I loved it so much
yeah that is a great shot I want to I
want to finish it I didn't finish it for
me I mean I watched some of the later
ones I watched Deep Space nine and
there's one on right now that I think is
spectacular that I haven't watched
although we have talked about how much I
liked the orbble but yeah if you would
watch one one style of Star Trek
whatever you want to call it I'd say the
next generation is my favorite I'm
biased it's like the conversation of
like whoever was spider-man or Batman
when you were a kid is your Batman yeah
yeah who was your battery Michael Keaton
mine's Val Kilmer thank you mr. Val
Kilmer was better Ginsberg Val camera
was better humor some child in the chat
says Ben Affleck that's Julian's
impression of Adam Levine at the Super
Bowl
[Music]
Oh multiplicity yeah Michael Keaton what
a legend wait do not what a legend who's
your Superman cuz mine is can or not
keeping oh my god I'm so very
Christopher Routh Sam loved loved loved
his Superman yes the best
my next one what Friday Night Lights see
okay that's an honorable mention for me
because I was a full-blown adult when I
watched it I don't perfect age when that
came out there's like every bone in my
body wishes that I never saw it so I
could experience it again for the first
time I'm gonna re-watch it at some point
I haven't rewatched it since literally
college I watched the last time I saw an
episode of Friday Night Lights in its
entirety is I think college like I
watched it when I was in college but
that show was so [ __ ] important to me
man a green karmic good god something
sentimental and important to you
it's timing and always like that too if
you have not seen Friday Night Lights
the TV show Friday Night Lights is some
of the best television that I've ever
experienced but like I it's meaningful
to me kind of like you said you know
some of the shows that you watch growing
up were meaningful to you in that like
it affected you at that age and then it
changed you it's influenced you as a
person I feel like Friday Night Lights
did that I feel like I had I was an
athlete I played baseball for a while
baseball was my entire life for a very
long time and watching that show and
learning you know the lessons that they
show you about like people and community
and friends and hardship and sports and
everything you know was so just it hit
home in I love that show well especially
now watching it back and so many of
those people became really huge stars
yeah but I looked at the kitchen to
Taylor Kitsch like nobody else my car is
literally named big Tim Riggins yeah I
saw him at the airport one time and I
couldn't breathe the same air out in a
corner I in like the most normal way I
had a picture of him on my wall I took a
cut out of one of his Sports Illustrated
only licked it once a day only once a
day and once a night I had a picture of
him cuz I was like really into fitness
and I was like he got in a great shape
after the [ __ ] and this was like after
you know the show was done and he was
kind of turning into a star but yeah
like dude amazing amazing saw in the
airport I couldn't believe that that was
well I couldn't believe
um yeah I don't lights great show yeah
we are both to two of the same people
that are far too shy to ever walk up to
someone and be like it's not in shyness
for I'm too shy I'm not shy I'm shy I
would do it it's not about shyness
though it's about that fear that I would
ruin everything well - because if if it
goes wrong then then there's no going
back you can't watch a show with that
person anymore and not think about it
well I've heard he's unbelievably nice
but like I'm too shy I think the only
person I ever might want to like just
say hi to just because I love them so
[ __ ] much is Keanu Reeves if I ever
saw oh yeah maybe say hi one time GSP
walked in front of me and I stopped
breathing
I stopped breathing
yeah someone in front of me was like hey
GSP can I take a picture with you and
he's like yeah sure and he stands there
and I just was like look I'm gonna pass
out remember I was like 26 - like he's
just a full-grown adult just like stops
breathing sick good times dude what's
your name man
literally nothing yeah if you haven't
seen Friday Night Lights oh do you want
a hug Kyle Chandler is in it if you know
who that is I have the Simpsons because
when I was a kid that was the show it
was just the best of the best the top of
the top the funniest family good time
happy show I have so many memories of
like there being a snow days like you
remember now so when you're dragging
your ass to go work or do whatever it is
you have to do and you're like men I'd
give anything just to have a day lay on
the couch and watch blink yes this
Simpsons was that show for me from like
childhood until high school hmm
like I would love I have memories of you
know we would wake up super early check
the weather see if we'd have a snow day
you know we'd never had a snow day
we had enough room to put the snow so
unfortunately we've go to school and
every six [ __ ] feet of snow but like
if we would get a snow day and we could
watch The Simpsons on Channel seven like
that was the best day ever
you could watch some in the morning go
outside go sledding have a great snow
day have some hot chocolate hang out
with mommy snuggle yeah watch The
Simpsons just the happiest and you could
watch it
that's awesome night it was I think the
Simpsons is the same for a lot of people
yeah I think that was that was their
show mm-hmm I never got I don't think I
just think the timing was weird for me I
like when it was starting and popular I
was too young
that's like spongebob for me yeah the
timing was off yeah timing was off but I
mean I'll watch an episode here and
there and I'll get it and it's funny you
know I appreciate how long it's been
going and how funny it's remained it's
very similar to Family Guy in that way
but a much more family-friendly version
well you just thought it was so [ __ ]
funny yeah Simpsons okay well the next
one you can definitely guess I don't
know the office you know how those come
in that was my comfort show I had a lot
of weird years in college where I like
kind of just was alone and that was my
comfort oh yeah watch that a lot I also
see you're all of yours are like too old
I tried to pick ones that were like when
I was younger I just didn't have that
many you know I didn't watch yeah you
know I watched like [ __ ] from time to
time I watched like my brother and I
used to watch UFC unleashed which was
literally just like highlight after
highlight of like UFC fights and that's
how we became you see and we like to
watch highlights and became just like
enamored with it but yeah
thank you good Michael Berg is
applauding somewhere thank you Michael
yeah the office I mean no explanation
necessary really it's just like one of
those shows that's transcended it's that
for so many people yeah just an
incredible it's it for me that's my
comfort show you know if I am staying in
a hotel by myself away from you and
things are weird or I'm you know I'm
getting a little homesick I'll just pop
on the office I don't feel okay that's
kind of like that show for me but
obviously it's you know when I was in
college I didn't have like comfort shows
we didn't have the ability to like watch
anything back really you know unless you
recorded it well you could schedule a
recording I think but like I didn't have
that but I'm well I just couldn't like
wait to watch Flavor of Love like this
that was like a golden era of I Love New
York
like the shittiest shitty [ __ ] insane
reality TV show Bret Michaels Rock of
Love like we had it in the bag like it
was [ __ ] poppin off on vh1 every
[ __ ] night you know you haven't
watched Flavor of Love do it yeah what
is your are you out are you have two
more America's Funniest Home Videos
which host um Bob Saget Bob Saget when I
was a kid I mean I watched all of them
yeah I'm bergeron or whatever and Daisy
Fuentes and Mark Fugelsang or whatever I
think like yeah I watched I watched them
all the way through high school I loved
that show yeah we didn't have YouTube I
couldn't sit around and laugh whenever I
wanted I was lead-in to the show yeah
you're right that was the thing back
then that was what you watched it was
mindless entertainment I could not wait
to sit and watch and just [ __ ] cry
laugh because I thought they were so
funny
and before that right I mean before that
on a major scale of millions of viewers
there was no there was nothing like it
know where millions of people could
watch
the Home Videos of other people when you
watch him back now for the most part
they're all so stale
they're so stale and weird sound effects
yeah but that was like you said that's
like what the early days of YouTube were
like yeah
but it was before that I just thought it
was the funniest thing ever it was the
funniest [ __ ] show in the world
everything was hysterical I did like
watching people win money I thought that
was really cool yeah and I always
thought someday that could be us you
know someday someday mom I'm gonna win
us $10,000 on America's Funniest Home
Video if I could just catch my favorite
doing something funny you know but we
didn't really have like a good camcorder
yeah I just loved that and then when I
was in college it was signing on to
Ebaum's world or he bombs world stupid
videos was what I found with my roommate
Ashley and we would just sit there and
laugh at stupid videos for hours
yeah literally and now here I am just
being a major participant on the
internet every day and now AFV has
turned into a tick-tock I love to talk
no but like I will there's no part of me
that I will always love stuff like that
always hates me right in like the
original fields of what actually makes
me laugh yeah for sure
what stupidest I think that I think that
sort of that format like lends itself
most to that it's funny [ __ ] I like it
because it's not there's no it's like
the blessing and the curse of something
like Tech Talk you don't know what
you're watching but at the end of the
day you know you're watching yeah it's
like good and dad but like to the
beginning of this conversation when we
started talking about Tech Talk like I
know so many people like you and that
you're like I don't think that stuff's
that funny or like you do think it's
funny but like you don't see it the way
that I see it like I there's like a high
that I get from digging through
thousands of shitty videos to find one
that makes me cry laughing like that to
me is like watching America's Funniest
Home Videos yeah
like I'll sit there because maybe
there's that one video in there
somewhere that I'm gonna absolutely piss
myself laughing at yeah
I'm waiting for that one what about when
the next like small video app comes out
are you gonna jump on the own and watch
always yeah well hopefully another one
comes out soon because I like to talk
but I think that we could do better I
don't I love it well I think you do
better I think it's great I watched vine
until the day it was [ __ ] not buying
anymore
when everyone else had jumped ship and
said [ __ ] vine I was still on there
looking for funny stuff okay I remember
that for hours you have one more no I
have one more I have my last one is
Breaking Bad see I knew you were gonna
have the office of Breaking Bad well if
I were to choose which one was more
influential I would say Breaking Bad
mm-hmm office was a comfort show and I
loved watching it but Breaking Bad has
been one of the most influential shows
to me as someone who uses cameras I have
like fallen so in love with everything
that show has done with their just
visual storytelling you and there's a
cinematography I know I sound stupid
when I say that but it's just like it
really taught me so much about how to
make a huge impact with a very minimal
style of shooting sometimes and things
that you might not think about have an
impact that you won't understand till
you actually try that sort of thing
in addition I just think it's like a
fantastic show tugs at your heartstrings
like it sucks you in from the first
episode and it wraps up you know in a
really really good horrifying scary but
like amazing way but yeah as far as like
the things I shoot I draw inspiration
from Breaking Bad all the time yeah yeah
and it made Albuquerque New Mexico
someplace that I just constantly want to
go look at and just explore and I can
you guess my last let's see do I get it
come forget any sort of hints oh no he's
cool
can you answer a question if I ask is it
a game show no oh but the price is ready
to say The Price is Right
oh man I so watch I shall I read I have
like an autographed picture of Bob
Barker which is one of my favorite
things I know that I have absolutely
loved that show
- ramped about being on it someday and
when in both shows showcases beats oh my
[ __ ] god
yeah I'm struggling I need some sort of
hint or you just tell them okay
it was then black and white go kermy
kermy speak that that that specifically
says it's big sorry I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
can we come I'm up here anyways I
thought that show was so funny and we
had something like I watched on
Nickelodeon and it told you and we had
something called Nick at Nite and they
would play which and I Lucy not Sabrina
Sabrina the Teenage Witch you said B
wishes me no but I really liked the
Nickelodeon version of that with
Clarissa explains it all forget I'm her
real name is escaping me we're Marisa
Melissa Joan Hart there you go loved I
loved Clarissa explains it all come here
but no the actual yeah bewitched but I
Love Lucy a special show for you and I'm
sure like so many for something [ __ ]
yeah do you know it's a trip to watch it
back now like any show but they're like
you know she's holding an infant and
smoking a cigarette and like they sleep
in two little separate beds her and
Ricky so that it's like I watch an
episode recently together it was the
first episode I've ever seen yeah cuz we
were in the waiting room well-marbled
was at the vet yes but regardless I
watched an episode of I Love Lucy and
I'm
I had not watched one before I mean that
show is like ultimate feels nostalgia
happy laughing so silly so fun like so
fun to watch the star of the show and
the funniest person on the show be this
like young funny quirky woman absolutely
hysterical
I loved it yeah and yeah I'd say that
was definitely one of the most
influential shows for me definitely cuz
it was she was just so [ __ ] goofy yeah
you know yeah I just seemed like free
and silly and fun and I just thought
that that was so rad and cool and it was
actually funny it made me laugh for sure
yeah it holds up I mean it's funny show
it is a funny show and funny about it so
for those of you that watched I Love
Lucy you know the famous Chocolate
Factory scene where they're just like
shoving chocolates in their mouths as
they come out on this conveyer belt
because they don't know what to do
faster and faster
and so Julian had seen that but we were
thinking John I think you would gotten
like your wisdom teeth out or something
was that it or you were sick or
something you really on the couch and I
was like Julian often times will be like
put something on for me like mindless
with that's either like the office or
Drake and Josh like something that's
gonna make him you know yeah better so I
turned on Drake and Josh for Julian and
there's they're doing that scene but
with like sushi or something yes sushi
and Julian's like laughing and I was
like you know this you ever seen the the
chocolate episode with I Love Lucy and
Julian's like no what's that
it's from chicken I'm just like a total
below laughing something I had no idea
was like an homage most yeah the most
sort of like it's been done in somebody
shows over and over and over and over
yeah that was I mean Josh Peck was an
incredible [ __ ] actor in that show
and like him in that scene with the
sushi was very hilarious again a show
that I never watched until I was an
adult but like I genuinely appreciate
that show yeah he is really spectacular
mm-hmm yeah it's a good show oh yeah
yeah
legend legendary show yeah that's on my
honorable mention mm-hmm
so is I didn't mention important things
is Demetri Martin nice honorable mention
oh what a show on MTV right it was you
know I actually forget what it was I
feel you I want like reminded me of like
Netflix I know it wasn't on Netflix but
it reminded me of mmm like it might have
been MTV I don't even remember I don't
have to look it up but I loved that show
yeah I can't remember that's always
funny is follow mentions there was never
a show like it Demetri Martin is just
funny yeah yeah he's very funny I guess
same live one time you did I don't know
I don't remember why I don't even know
if we were dating when I saw him you
should take me now you know once I what
we weren't dating when I know it was
when I was young it was when I was
really young I remember now I remember
not Oh
joke I was like why don't you take me no
no I was trying remember when it when I
actually saw him but it was when I was
really young it was promise probably
like not even that like but like not in
the recent years it was like I was 18 or
19
not really but not yesterday Herman what
was your favorite show cry yeah we just
give you a minute you do something nasty
no bud oh oh thank you guys for hanging
out hopefully you enjoyed us talking
about TV I think this would be a fun one
to do with movies at some point - mmm oh
it's gonna be hard that's gonna be much
harder but well maybe you'll have more
that like influenced you as a kid
because you saw movies as a kid right
yeah that's true I did see movies as a
kid I went to the cinema I went to the
theater a lot with my dad that was like
a thing we did
I think it was a bad thing it is a dad
thing dad's dad's be like dad's be like
let's go out to dinner tonight
and then this weekend we'll go to the
movies food movie night on the weekend
was the best I was the best I remember
walking in just a little bit late to see
Beauty and the Beast in the movie
theatre with my dad and we sat like all
the way against the side and the wall
says the only place we can get seats
because it was packed and that [ __ ]
movie just blew my mind I was like dad
do you understand what we're watching
right now this is [ __ ] insane down he
was like yeah Jenna sick I think I
brought you here well anyway thank you
guys for hanging out we appreciate you
we hope you have a wonderful week also
if you're a fan of the twitch stream
tune in tonight okay okay
tune in tonight we have an interesting
announcement you guys have a great week
be good we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]